all right kevin show us three popular
emoji faces
[Applause]
what is my biggest fear
nicking his privates uh when
shaving that's a good one i didn't think
about this one
wow i know that for you i wouldn't be
scared we've had a couple drinks
together haven't we
wow so we know what your favorite hobby
is how do you remember all your
passwords
oh wow that's a great question jimmy i'd
have to say telekinesis
telekinesis yes you're able to move
things around no i tell a few of my
nieces
put it in their phone and they remember
it for me
what do you want for your birthday
everything where does mrs mumfree live
in my house what's the worst thing you
could put in coffee
how many times i say bat
why is richard the best just because
uh who do i look like
uh my mom
let me ask you something if i
say hey i think it may be madrid or
lisbon and then the 5050 comes it's not
going to say madrid elizabeth
you don't know okay 50 50. let's do it
computer take away two of those wrong
answers
you think the president jerks off in the
oval office not only do i think he does
i think they all do and you have to as a
man the first day what can we do for you
president and they already know what
you're going to say i uh
would just like to have everybody get
out of the office
for about four minutes
thank you and everybody knows what
you're doing you know
and i think even the illuminati shuts
off their cameras
is jennifer lawrence
quitting hollywood i don't know if it'll
be my choice
i think i'm more likely to be fired
who's most likely to survive a real-life
jungle cruise adventure that would be
new because you have more fat on you
so you'd last longer
look at everybody's head popped up all
right kanye give us three things that
are hairy balls balls
[Applause]
how did matt damon get into harvard was
it legitimate i applied
i i heard jared kushner's parents paid
like two and a half million bucks oh
yeah we didn't have we didn't roll like
that no i actually had to apply that's
impressive if i wasn't an actor what
would i do for a living i i was going to
say he'd be a general in the armed
forces of some kind which i think is
pretty pretty great or
a pumpkin butter salesman
just a door-to-door pumpkin butter
salesman dj is always unexpected in his
entrepreneurial pursuits so i yeah
it's a scalable business it's a growth
industry so i don't know maybe yeah name
something that a person might take a
picture of then post it to facebook
i'm sorry
what did you say
i say it or i just think
okay girls take pictures of boobs oh
boobs
yeah let's go to the boards
[Applause]
so i have a twin brother whoa
no incredible no no no i don't i ate my
twin brother in the womb
okay ricky the golden globe statue is
round name three other things that
around the earth
my balls
[Applause]
who's most likely to be caught napping
between takes actually it's usually me
during dwayne's close-up
oh that was good is that right yeah is
that how we're gonna play
that's the game we're gonna play okay
here we go my spouse gives the best
no my parents are here
he checks my oil put your look the
fingers are in the ear checking he's
really good at checking oil
does samuel l jackson like anime yes i
do hentai too
what uh what's your best beauty tip my
best beauty tip
let it hang
let it hang
yeah
yep
just let it hang
it's i mean why not right
who's the funniest person in the cast
jack probably no you her because with
her british sense of um no and she likes
to say no i don't really
i've never said it
what's the worst job you've ever had i
never had a job besides your face what
body part do you look at the most in the
mirror
i
i don't want to look at it
but
the thing
what did ricky gervais say to mel gibson
oh i think i know what they mean
when he was at the podium like the last
time i introduced him
i said
what does sugar even mean i think that's
why they i think that's what they're
referring to they must have bleeped out
the word
i like it when my man gives me a big
i can't say the answer i want to say
so i'm gonna say gift
i'm gonna just say
uh what on screen the co-star were you
most nervous to kiss the rock
i kissed him and get smart and how was
that pretty great yeah
kevin besides the heart name three other
organs
lung kidneys
that's not an organ
i didn't say guy you said thy he said
thyroid it's a thigh it's a tiny royal
man zipper breaks the church what might
he use to cover it up a child
whoa
a what a child
i met a baby
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm feeling